the 1224 calendar is here get it now
before it sells out and stay tuned until
the end of this video for a sneak peek
that's out of this
world life has existed on one planet for
about 4 billion years as far as we know
but it might have started right after
the big bang when the universe was much
stranger and more fantastic than today a
universe that might have allowed life to
develop absolutely anywhere the cosmos
might full of the seeds of Life sleeping
in a dead desert waiting for a few drops
of rain to explosively bloom and grow
tiny and not so tiny aliens might be
everywhere in this video we're going to
put together two highly speculative yet
scientifically grounded possibilities
check out the scientific papers in our
sources to properly explain it let's
first look at the Paradox of life on
Earth the life
paradox for its first few hundred
million years Earth was a magma hell
constantly bombarded by asteroids but
basically the second things calmed down
and the first oceans formed life just
appeared and zillions of microbes
settled every nook and cranny they found
this is kind of strange life on Earth
seems to be almost as old as the planet
itself as if it was waiting around for
an opportunity but life didn't only
appear extremely quickly in that tiny
time window it also crossed a huge gap
to qualify as living things even
microbes need to eat poop grow and
multiply to do that they need a genome
the biological instruction manual that
sets the inner workings of an organism
how dead things with no genome become
living things with genomes is one of the
biggest riddles of science simplifying a
lot the problem is that to have a
functioning genome you need proteins and
to make those proteins you need a
functioning genome both proteins and
genomes are super long molecules made of
pretty complex blocks that are extremely
difficult to assemble by chance it's a
chicken egg Paradox with several
chickens and eggs once you have a
finished cell the whole system works
efficiently but starting from simple
dead stuff and reaching that level of
sophistication by pure chance should
require an amazing amount of time for
trial and error so how did the first
living things manage to cross that Gap
in just a few 100 million years most
theories about the origin of Life try to
explain that Gap by theorizing how some
primitive soup of Prebiotic molecules
could have efficiently produced the
first self-replicating entities but we
still don't know how exactly this would
have worked maybe we need to think
backwards the clock of
evolution think of genomes as a book
telling the history of Life As Time
passed and life evolved more characters
were introduced amoeba fish amphibians
dinosaurs and
mammals over billions of years the story
of Life got more and more complex a
genome can be viewed as a long string of
letters with biological instructions and
from microbes to us today functional
genomes seem to have been increasing in
size at a fairly constant rate the
functional Genome of fish is more than
twice that of worms our functional
genome is about twice bigger than that
of fish and so on it is a bit more
complicated but for now let's run with
this when we put all these Clues
together it seems that genomes have been
doubling in size on average every 350
million years or so as if evolution had
been following an exponential inner
clock but it gets even
stranger the very first microbes that
emerged on Earth even if they look
simple already seem to have had pretty
long and complex genomes
but how could life have achieved that
level of complexity in such a short time
there may be an interesting way to solve
this riddle we just take our exponential
clock and extrapolate it back in time to
the simplest conceivable life form
something equivalent to a being with a
genome containing just a few letters but
if we do that we end up 10 billion years
in the past more than twice the age of
Earth which means if life actually
evolves like this it didn't start here
but somewhere out there in space this
would explain why life started to thrive
so quickly on our young Planet if it was
already present in space like a seed it
just needed water and warm temperatures
to wake up and go on evolving and it
would also explain the high degree of
sophistication of the first life forms
on Earth they could have been complex
already because they might have been
evolving for billions of years somewhere
else in the universe but could life
really be that old maybe Yes actually
life could have started shortly after
the universe itself was born a goldilock
baby
Universe At Its most basic level life
needs two things the right chemical
elements to form complex molecules and a
liquid medium like water in which those
molecules can move and interact the
liquid medium needs to stay warm enough
to remain well liquid so when we search
for life in space we focus on earthlike
planets at just the right distance from
their star warm enough to sustain liquid
water but there was actually a time when
almost all of the universe might have
been habitable right after the big bang
the universe was extremely hot but as
the cosmos expanded it cooled and
between about 10 and 17 million years
after the big bang when the universe was
a thousand times younger than today it
was between 100° C and 0° C the
temperature at which water is liquid so
for this window of time more than 13.7
billion years ago the whole universe
absolutely every inch of it had the
right temperature to support life of
course the right temperature alone is
not enough for life we also need
chemical elements like carbon and oxygen
which are forged in the cores of stars
but were there stars in super early
Cosmic times maybe yes in regions of the
Universe where matter was especially
dense such Stars would have been very
massive and gone Supernova in just 3
million years seeding the baby Universe
with the chemical elements needed to
form dust asteroids planets and the
ingredients of Life maybe the first
ancestors of life were more exotic and
didn't even need water but thrived in
substances like ammonia or ethane that
can stay liquid at temperatures far
below 0° C they could have been
sustained by the lingering warmth of the
big bang for tens of millions of years
longer well into a time when we know for
sure there were stars and all the
chemical elements the real magic of this
idea is that while the universe today is
extremely deadly and hostile back then
the conditions for life might have been
basically everywhere for a period that
may have lasted several dozen million
years primordial life might have been
able to emerge on any Rock even between
the Stars sewing the universe with the
SE of what billions of years later would
become bacteria trilobites dinosaurs and
finally
us at some point the universe cooled
down below the right temperature for
life to thrive but some of those
ancestral life forms may have continued
to exist in the internal warmth of the
first planets Frozen in asteroids or
hiberdating in Cosmic dust tiny seeds
roaming the cosmos waiting for new
hospitable places to continue evolving
if they did life now might be everywhere
in the
universe will we ever
know all this makes for a nice story and
while both the habitability of the baby
universe and our exponential clock of
Life are reasonable ideas they're still
speculative one more possibility among
many others trying to explain our
existence today but if life came to
Earth from outer space then it should
have seeded other places in the solar
system too maybe there are fossils in
dry riverbeds on Mars maybe we'll soon
find life in the warm underground oceans
of Enceladus or Europa Titan has Seas
rivers and lakes of ethane and methane
as warm as the universe when it was 90
million years old so finding Exotic Life
on Titan would support the idea that
life could have originated in the weird
baby universe so far when we look out
into the cosmos we don't see anyone like
us but maybe that's because life needed
10 billion years or more to reach the
level of complexity that allows for a
technological species maybe there are
millions of Worlds filled with microbes
oceans full of exotic fish and
continents of bizarre animals and maybe
even others like us that just recently
gained Consciousness and are beginning
to look at the sky wondering if they're
alone life could be flourishing right
now in uncountable forms and in all
kinds of cosmic environment and if many
of us share a common Cosmic origin we
would all be part of a great Cosmic
Family the answer May lie in our Cosmic
backyard let's go and find
out it's time let's reveal the 1224
human era calendar with a big bang the
ktz gazar calendar is special because
we're adding 10,000 years to include all
of humanity no matter their culture or
origin 12,000 years ago humans first
started working together on a larger
scale laying the foundation for
civilization and the future of us all a
much better representation of how far
our species has come this year we're
looking at the cosmos and all the
possible life that could be thriving on
myriads of Worlds hosting radically
different animals and beings from the
ones on Earth where in the universe
might life exist and how would different
Cosmic environments affect the basic
rules of Life join us in 12, 24 and find
out explore strange Cosmic habitats and
extraterrestrial life forms on 12 for or
inspiring Pages there's also lots of
room for you to keep track of your life
here on Earth add some serious space
magnificence to your home but be careful
the extremely radiant cover May blind
you get the calendar now before it sells
out we also have bundles and special
calendar deals with some of your
favorite products thank you so much to
all of the thousands of bird who get the
calendar every year with every purchase
you support the kot Kazan division of
sparking curiosity and inspiring people
all around the world we wish you an epic
year
[Music]